you're introducing a cancer into your
culture eventually you're going to have
to do surgery and cut it out I don't
know where this started it's the worst
idea I've ever heard
[Applause]
[Music]
so quiet quitting a temporary pandemic
hangover byproduct of low unemployment
or a long-term thing
you know Chef the economy is changing
obviously we're going into a whole new
metric where some people work at home
some people work a distance some people
go back to the office we don't know how
it's going to shape out in the long run
it's more Project based and the other
otherwise you're hired and you're
trusted to finish things off now some
ideas are bad ideas and some ideas are
stupid ideas but very rarely can you
combine both and that's what we have
here this is the dumbest idea I've ever
heard in launching a career and what I'm
hoping I can do and I've told the
recruiters because I've got about 10 000
people in inside of the companies that
were investors in plus the supply chains
I've asked them can we identify these
people early and help them get jobs with
our competitors because this is the most
competitive weapon I've ever seen if
you're a quiet quitter you're a loser
you're Un-American that's what I think
you know workers are so in demand we
started talking I don't know a year and
a half ago about how power to the
workers power to the workers this is
part of that right
it could be but really your job is to
find something you're passionate about
and find a way to work with your team
really it's about culture you know I'm
an investor in small business in America
50 to 500 million that is 65 of our
economy these are family businesses you
build a culture when you bring somebody
in that slams shut their laptop at five
o'clock you're introducing a cancer into
your culture eventually you're going to
have to do surgery and cut it out the
whole idea would be avoid these people I
don't know where this started it's the
worst idea I've ever heard because it's
against what we do in business we try
and build teams that work together to
achieve something set objectives and
work together it doesn't matter whether
you're working anymore at six a.m or two
in the morning you're just getting your
job done that's the freedom the economy
is giving you now in a distance basis
nobody's asking you to work nine to five
they're asking you to get your job done
if you walk in your interview and say I
only work from 90 to five then I stopped
working I can't wait to get you into my
competitor help me find these people
this is like a virus this is worse than
covet
all right I got it you're on the fence
about quiet quitting all day all day
long around here we've been reporting on
what an awful day it was on the street
do you see the market downward Trend
continuing now
yeah I do for a while I mean we've
really got to adjust to the hawkish
comments that pal made today and that's
okay I've seen this movie multiple times
any investor that's invested for more
than 20 years has been through multiple
Cycles like this and what happens is at
the end of the day you get that jolt
down almost a thousand points volatility
is really the Hallmark of Fed rate hikes
but we have a remarkably strong economy
chef and that's because we printed over
six trillion dollars and it's still
flawed sloshing around out there the
reason we have inflation is we keep
printing so you know we've got a lot of
bills keep printing money we're going to
have this problem systemically so we
stop doing this and you can debate the
politics of it but the midterms are
coming and I'm going to uh making a you
know an assumption right now that after
the midterms there'll be no more bills
printing any more money not that I want
to get into politics but I think we're
done doing this now
you know Fed chair Powell said more rate
hikes are coming sounds like more and
more are coming until they see inflation
is under control is that the right move
I think it is because we're at 8.2
percent so if you're sitting in cash
you're basically being taxed at eight
percent but really half of this
inflation supply chain damage and so
what we really need to do is actually
we've got this remarkable situation
we've never had before we're at full
employment with remarkably
hyperinflation that's never happened
before so you have to start to question
the productivity of Full Employment we
need more employees in all businesses to
fix the supply chain problem so I'm
hoping the FED in Palestine a masterful
job I really have to give him credit on
at least not popular everywhere but he's
really trying to land that plane he's
doing a good job he's trying to job own
it a bit but at the end of the day half
our problems just fix our supply chain
I've got companies that can't buy
anything anymore because they can't get
the supplies out of the Port of Los
Angeles we have to make it here 30 more
expensive we got a lot of work to do in
this economy but I'm always bullish I
love entrepreneurship and that's why as
we started talking about quiet quitting
just say no if you like that video will
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe